[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mí me gusta cocinar
y me gusta cocinar y busco en youtube
las recetas de cocina tengo muchos
libros de cocina tengo mi recetario pero
voy a hacerles
nunca me salen las recetas igual como
salen de las fotos
me he comprado batidora me ha comprado
de todo lo que hay y no me resulta pero
ningún dado y lo interesante es que en
la medida que voy avanzando creo que
cocino muy bien pero no es la misma
manera que me aparece en la fotografía
es algo curioso porque me sucede
exactamente lo mismo cuando los
profesores en la universidad me
preguntan cuál es la receta para ser
buen profesor cuál es la receta para que
el profesor o yo como profesor sea capaz
de eventualmente hacer buenas clases y
también los estudiantes me dice pero a
ver pues de la receta para que yo pueda
aprender más como si fuera algo
instantáneo de seguir paso a paso
etcétera etcétera
miren más o menos un poco más de 15 años
se empezó una revolución importante en
latinoamérica en ir actualizando los
currículos formativos y pensábamos que
actualizar los currículos formativos era
cambiar la receta
y yo me encontraba con ese desafío y de
hecho me tocó en latinoamérica y
nuestros países iberoamericanos diseñar
hasta el momento 168 por el club por
competencia que hacía el enfoque que
ahora se ha desarrollado mucho pero
cuando iba en el 100 dije a ver de qué
sirve tener estos elementos marcos si
otros frameworks y al final del día
cuando uno iba a la sala la gente hacía
más de lo mismo
teníamos la receta pero lo que pasaba
dentro del aula no tenía nada que ver
con la receta
y en ese proceso cuando vemos que
profesores y estudiantes verá que hay un
desafío distinto ya no podemos pensar de
que el currículum simplemente es una
receta que tengo que aplicar y el
comienzo a preguntarme cómo podríamos
hacer esta experiencia de facilitación
para profesorado y para estudiantes de
poder insertarse a la vida universitaria
bajo estos nuevos desafíos que no
enfrentaba la formación y empecé a
partir de un grupo de universidades que
me creyeron lo que estaba diciendo y que
al parecer había experiencias
internacionales y empezar a crear
ciertas vías de apoyo y de trabajo con
docentes inicialmente
a poco andar me di cuenta que no bastaba
con apoyar solamente al docentes sino
que era muy necesario también apoyar al
estudiante por tanto entre lo que usaba
con estudiantes que sucedía con el
profesor necesitábamos eventualmente
construir una comunidad de éste
y ahí donde comienzo a trabajar con
centros de enseñanza aprendizaje ya hace
pocos días ya son 37 centros que me ha
tocado acompañar y trabajar en estos
temas y lo que uno va aprendiendo al
final del día es de qué manera más que
dar recetas a profesores y estudiantes
es de qué manera somos capaces de
ofertar de ofrecer ciertas orientaciones
y criterios que se ajustan las
realidades de las personas de los
contextos de las situaciones que van a
originar
lo interesante es que estas experiencias
han estado unidades del centro de
enseñanza aprendizaje no son nuevas en
el mundo las primeras nacen a mitad del
siglo 20
de hecho en chile me encontrado con que
la grata sorpresa que al final en los 60
había aquí en la universidad de chile
algunas facultades que teníamos unidades
como ésta allá y que después con y otros
países también en latinoamérica tenían
pero claramente con los cambios
vertiginoso que hubo en los 70 el final
de los 60 en varios países está unida
desaparecieron y han vuelto a resurgir
con fuerza ya con desde el 2000 más o
menos 2008 2007 en adelante en toda la
región
y estas unidades son tremendamente
importante porque esta unidad es al
final del día
lo que hacen es que en los modelos
educativos institucionales esto que
queda tan teórico queda tan digamos
dentro del marco genérico logran ser
implementado en la cotidianidad
formativa por tanto siempre se planteó y
creo que si el corazón de la formación y
el corazón son los proyectos educativos
y los aprendizajes curriculares los
centros de enseñanza y aprendizaje son
el sistema circulatorio porque eso lo
que te permiten eventualmente hacer que
este proyecto que lo declaró
eventualmente el círculo y así una
experiencia muy interesante el poder ver
cómo ha sucedido hay experiencias que
han funcionado otra casa muerto otra que
ha tenido grandes éxitos otras
claramente que vale un proceso de
ascenso pero también hay aprendizaje que
uno va detectando y que claramente son
relevantes y que son importante de
visualizar y esto su aprendizaje que me
ha tocado visualizar y aprender
claramente se lo quiero compartir
en este momento y primera cosa dentro de
los aprendizajes tienen que ver siempre
la pregunta es para qué son estas
unidades para qué sirven y al final uno
lo que mira es que no solo unidades de
capacitaciones no solo unidades de
necesariamente atención sino son
unidades que deben lograr promover
cambios culturales que cambio culturales
es como se enseña y cómo se aprende
y estos son cambios culturales a muy
largo plazo bastante hasta que ustedes
vean por ejemplo
la mañana antes de que despertara
quisieran que se pueda contar obvio ya
pero que hicieron y se dan cuenta que
son rutinas las culturas son rutinas
y en la universidad tenemos rutinas si
ustedes ven por ejemplo porque tenemos
16 semana en la universidad tenemos 10
semanas de clase aproximadamente
nosotros era porque unirse a harvard
tiene 16 semanas
ustedes saben porque lo necesitaba ha
tenido seis semanas
porque la universidad de oxford tiene 16
semanas y ustedes saben por qué porque
universidad o aporte 16 semana es porque
el tiempo que existe entre
la siembra navidad y la cosecha
y qué hacemos a la universidad es que
siempre se crece
entonces claramente hay rutinas que hay
que cambiar quizás significativas como
por ejemplo comprender que ya tenemos
neurociencia que hay aprendizaje debemos
comprender que estamos en una generación
distinta de estudiantes conocer quiénes
son mis estudiantes es como lo que es
conocer cómo aprender
y ahí tenemos el desafío importante los
cambios culturales un segundo elemento
muy relevante tiene que ver que este
tipo de unidades tiene que comprender la
cultura institucional a mí me preguntan
siempre pero qué estructura tiene que
tener el centro qué forma tiene cómo
tiene que organizarse y digo no sé
entonces que quedan mirando pero como
que no sabe no sé por qué hay que
comprender que le hace sentido a esta
cultura en particular las universidades
somos grandes culturas y después
culturas acotadas en un facultad incluso
departamentos por tanto comprender las
culturas es comprender también cómo
vamos ajustándonos a estos contextos
como tal y cómo nos vamos organizando
pero claramente un centro de enseñanza
aprendizaje sí o sí una condición sine
qua non es profesores estudiantes y
medición
y todos los aspectos de un aspecto que
puedan apoyar a que esto fluya de manera
más natural
otro elemento importante tiene que ver
que los centros tienen ser capaces de
promover experiencias que vayan en la
frontera especialmente en la frontera de
la enseñanza en las disciplinas el hacer
avanzar la enseñanza de la disciplina no
solamente hace el avance la disciplina
en conocimiento sino cómo se enseña esta
disciplina yo siempre me preguntan que
mejor un centro central a nivel
universidad o un centro local mire yo
digo depende del grupo que tenga o
depende del tamaño la universidad pero
también depende las culturas
tengo que comprender que al final cada
disciplina también hay una forma de
hacer las cosas distintas y eso hay que
tenerlo tenerlo muy presente porque
elementos muy importantes
poco poco práctico y también pierde la
esencia si los centros no tienen
trabajando y tienen y no trabajando
simplemente como ayudantes sino en
colaboración en corresponsabilidad
permanente estudiantes porque porque
sólo los estudiantes el que nos dan por
stuart en el feedback lo que está
sucediendo al interior del aula por
tanto los mejores digamos partes del
equipo del centro de enseñanza
aprendizaje son estudiantes
y yo le digo siempre profesionales de
información y qué mejor que también sean
de la disciplina o del área que está
trabajando por tanto son importantes
dentro del trabajo tener siempre manera
permanente estudiantes no sólo como
destinatario sino como corresponsables
dentro del proceso
es muy importante que los centros de
enseñanza aprendizaje también aprendan a
demostrar valor en su entorno el darse
cuenta que puede provocar en la cultura
el que está el tener que decir mira esto
es importante
entonces el tener que hacer que los
otros atribuyen valor es una tarea no
menor
de ahí la importancia de trabajar tanto
con profesores y estudiantes con
gestores con gestores institucionales es
decir son procesos que tienen que
intervenir todos los niveles para poder
asignarle valor a alguien es importante
ojo que es un valor cualitativo no
cuantitativo
cuál es el error típico que me preguntan
cuántos profesores capacitados
no sólo tienen un sentido más bien
pregúntate es como este tipo de unidad
ha cambiado en las culturas a partir de
que existe este tipo de experiencia al
interior de una unidad académica
instrumento importante del fenómeno
educativo es un fenómeno complejo
difícil y yo hablo que aprendido es que
lo que no funciona es pensar que esta
experiencia son para gente de educación
o sea es decir desde la pedagogía la
verdad que lo que yo aprendió es que es
un elemento pero no el único para poder
abordar en la universidad una situación
que es compleja debemos abordarlo
completamente y laborda la manera de
abordarlo completamente multidimensional
mente es teniendo distintos tipos
distintos profesionales disciplinares
ahí trabajando en el centro entre más
variedad mayor riqueza y ahí me
preguntan siempre como reclutó esta
gente porque claramente en el mercado no
hay verdad quien no es quién no a que no
exista lo que pasa que están buscando
mal lo que tenemos que buscar es gente
que sea flexible gente que aprenda a
aprender que se atreva a aprender que
aprenda es muy importante a trabajar en
contextos de incertidumbre
porque porque trabaja con el aprendizaje
con las culturas es complejos y por
tanto mi incertidumbre es algo
permanente es parte del trabajo del
incertidumbre pero también la innovación
es parte de la incertidumbre el innovar
es navegar el incertidumbre de que un
dato interesante cuando yo tengo un
estudio de 1.600 profesores
universitario en latinoamérica que
innovaron e interesante cuando innova
los desempeños bajan
pero en forma estadísticamente
significativa del grupo que hay un grupo
que deserta porque es cierta porque se
siente inseguro y los que siguen 12
meses después buenos resultados
es decir el tener que hacer cambios
dentro del proceso educativo ser cambio
en mis rutinas como docentes provoca
inseguridad por eso necesito unidades
como este que me acompañen a hacer estos
procesos no estoy solo
es muy importante que estas experiencias
están unidas sistematicen escriban lo
que está sucediendo ahí que aprendizaje
están logrando en este proceso de
interacción y de interpretación cultural
y de transformación hace un montón de
años me encontré con uno de los expertos
mundiales en esta temática de hace como
20 años en una conferencia y es como si
no como si los psicólogos terapeutas
encontraran con freud no sé los
economistas importan con adam poseen la
gente de salud con fleming más o menos
así como que recibe la voz y le
preguntan live
y yo le pregunté así todo cuanto se
habían demorado en gastre aceptó su
ritmo por competencia pues su momento es
el gran problema aquí en chile había
universidades que en un fin de semana
hacia el cambio y resulta que resulta y
me dice no es efecto y me dice todos
sonrientes me dice si yo me demoré 15
años como que te demoraste 15 años
porque son cambios culturales
no son cambios de recetas no son cambios
de métodos son también cultura y segunda
segundo los efectos dice mira no tengo
idea pero por primera vez los profesores
universitarios se sientan a conversar de
lo que quieren de la formación
y finalmente es tremendamente importante
es que estas unidades cuando uno mira
porque esta unidad es lo que me tocaba
vivir a mí funcionan o porque tienen un
éxito o porque son capaces de afectar o
impactar o han sido capaces de morir
tienen que ver que los liderazgos pero
no lideramos concentrados en un
liderazgo distribuido en los equipos
pero también que salieran de santos para
hacerse flexibles a los contextos que
puedan adaptarse pero también liderazgos
que sean inspiradores
liderazgo que pueda mostrar
hoy día hacia dónde tenemos que ir
mañana
y con el profesorado igual los centros
de enseñanza aprendizaje tienen que
instalar estudias campana de gauss hay
un grupo de profesores que con un vaso
de agua se motivan con arriba de la mesa
hipermotivado que leen toda la
metodología del otro lado de la campana
de gauss aunque tú traigas al experto
del mundo mundial no va a cambiar
y al medio la gran mayoría de profesor
la estrategia es claramente la gran
mayoría profesora hacerlo avanzar a
veces más rápido hace más lento y lo que
son hipermotivados necesitamos que estos
profesores hoy nos muestren lo que
necesitamos de la educación
universitaria del mañana prohibir y no
hacer mucho más en unos pocos
por eso es tremendamente importante
comprender de que estos procesos son
lentos o cambios culturales de este tipo
de unidades lo que hacen es ayudar
favorecer estos cambios suceden
nuevamente
el sistema circulatorio del proyecto al
corazón
vuelvo a mi receta de cocina
yo creo que como ven no tengo recetas
sobre la formación universitaria después
ha hecho muchos currículum haber hecho
muchos centros de enseñanza aprendizaje
ya hace una década mi vida te pregunta
cómo hacemos para influenciar ya no
solamente el aula sino como influirse
influenciamos al sector de la formación
entonces lo tengo metido en la gestión
de la formación y creo que es muy
importante comprender de que no tengo
las recetas no creo que haya recetas
pero sí aprendidos de la cocina que
puedo ocupar a lo mejor ingredientes
puedo tener distintos paladares que me
dan en el contexto pero al final del día
ya cada momento va a tener su gusto o
cada plato va a tener su sabor en el
momento
y con la universidad pasa un poco lo
mismo comprender de que la estructura la
universidad los equipos van marcando
claramente los timing en que las
situaciones se dan para que se provoque
los cambios
nos gustaría que el plato de mi cocina
quedara lo que yo cocino tiene al igual
que en la fotografía pero yo creo que no
le importa
lo importante es que al final del día
sea un buen plato
y también pase lo mismo con el
aprendizaje
no espero que sean aprendizajes ideales
esperamos que sea el aprendizaje
significativo para el estudiante para la
sociedad
quizás el capaz de transformar nuestro
mundo
[Aplausos]